this next story requires
some explanation but it's pretty
fascinating
a couple of days ago tucker carlson fox
news propagandist
ran a kind of strange out-of-place
commentary on his show
where he vaguely referred to his college
yearbooks
and people like jeff bezos looking for
dirt on tucker carlson and it was weird
because
it was just out of context it seemed to
have nothing to do with what was going
on on tucker's show
and it raised the question of whether
tucker carlson was trying to get ahead
of a maybe embarrassing or
problematic story so let's start by
taking a look at that this is the clip
from a couple of nights ago just kind of
out of nowhere we don't know what this
was about
a quick piece of news from the world of
big tech we spent the day hearing from
quite a few old college classmates in
some cases people we've been out of
touch with for 30 years
it was nice but here was the occasion
for it jeff
bezos had one of his minions a mentally
unbalanced middle-aged man called eric
wempel
pull our dusty college yearbook and call
around to see if we've done anything
naughty at the age of 19. that sounds
like fun
let us know if you hear any good stories
but before bezos drops any more of his
billions on opposition research you
should know that it will not affect
any election outcome this is a news show
it's not a political campaign
no one here is running for anything or
plans to on the other hand if jeff bezos
wants to come over to reminisce about
1987 on this show
he's always welcome anytime sort of a
strange story
in a vacuum but then yesterday
it all starts to become much clearer an
image purporting to be tucker carlson's
college yearbook entry from trinity
college in 1991
mentions that tucker was part of a
number of groups including
the christian fellowship okay the jesse
helms
foundation uh oh and something called
the dan
white society now for those wondering
whether this is even a real image
trinity college has confirmed that this
is their real 1991 yearbook
tucker's entry is on page 186 there is
no question about
it being real and this started to raise
some questions because
the dan white society references
dan white dan white was a guy who
killed san francisco mayor george
mascone
and supervisor harvey milk california's
first
openly gay elected official in 1978
dan white was a horrible person a
disgustingly violent homophobic
person and so when you look at tucker's
yearbook
and it says dan white society that's
starting to look not so good
and then our longtime friend jeremy
hooper
did some more research into this and
found a 1990 op-ed
by tucker carlson in his college
newspaper where he calls homosexuality
quote unnatural
and unhealthy and it is signed
tsm carlson and indeed jeremy confirmed
that tucker carlson is the only possible
student
with those initials at that time it also
appears as jeremy hooper points out on
twitter
that this is the only thing tucker ever
wrote in the newspaper meaning it's not
that tucker was a regular columnist
and it just so happened that one day he
wrote about
unnatural gay people he went out of his
way
to write one column one time about
his displeasure with the fact that gay
people
exist now to me this is less about
whether
tucker carlson was homophobic in 1990 or
1991
as a sort of potential disqualifier for
tucker to do
whatever today first of all there's tons
of people that are homophobic
secondly i don't think being homophobic
is considered a problem for fox news
host that may even
it may be a feature more than it is a
bug and third
most importantly in theory tucker's
views
may have changed over the last 30 years
i have views that are different today
than they were 30 years ago
and much like i would say about anyone
if these were tucker's views 30 years
ago and they appear to be
it doesn't necessarily tell us how his
views are today many of my views have
changed
although i was never anti-gay it's more
about the strange nature
of how tucker ended up getting into this
story earlier this week
doing this bizarre proactive segment to
attack
jeff bezos and to say people are
looking for dirt it's just all very
strange
now that being said yeah tucker's heroes
in college were really disturbing it's
not just
that he of the three groups he mentions
one
seems to be an adoration of the guy who
killed harvey milk for being gay
that's horrifying he also shouts out
jesse helms jesse helms used to be a
senator
who opposed the civil rights act opposed
the voting rights act called the civil
rights act
dangerous and on and on if these were
tucker's heroes then
i'd be curious as to who his heroes are
today it's really horrible stuff
i don't expect much more to come of it
you know anybody
oh he should be fired from fox news yeah
right even if fox news doesn't see this
as a feature
um it's not going to cause a problem for
tucker on fox news but a very strange
story and watching it develop it
watching it develop over the week
even stranger with the proactive oh
people are calling around looking for
dirt on me
really weird let me know what you make
of it i spend a lot of time every day
looking at a computer screen and
peer-reviewed studies have shown that
blue
light from screens can lead to eye
strain
blurred vision headaches dry watery eyes
that will not be a problem for you once
you get blue blocks
glasses which filter out blue light to
help your eyes
they are one of our sponsors today blue
blocks glasses are developed
and built in actual optics labs they've
been extensively tested for
effectiveness
there are over 40 different styles to
choose from
these are my blue blocks glasses i like
the look i've noticed a huge difference
where i'm not
getting that eye strain or the headaches
from the computer screen
because of the blue blocks glasses they
really have something for everyone a
prescription version
non-prescription reading glasses and
blue blocks is giving you
twenty percent off when you go to blue
blocks dot com slash pacman
and use the code pacman the link is
right underneath this video
and you will get free shipping on orders
over
a hundred and fifteen dollars